okay so i assume you've all got you know
textbooks
worksheets that your teachers give you
here are some places which
um i think are really useful for you
again don't worry too much about getting
the addresses
you can google them anyway um you've got
to go to the board of studies
okay the first thing you should do when
you go there is go and download what we
call
the syllabus now what is a syllabus
does anyone know how would you explain
you know in a sentence
what is a syllabus fantastic okay so i
think outline
is probably the best synonym for it okay
so the idea is look
for your tan these are the things that
you're expected to know and these are
the things you're expected to be able to
do the syllabus is what teachers and
exam writers and you guys should be
looking at
to know what's on there and then all
subjects is the same okay
one of the great things about the math
syllabus is that it's um it's really
detailed
it's what we call itemized so it's not
like you know
here's a general topic and you need to
know stuff about that they'll be like
you need to know the sine rule and the
cosine rule and what tan means and how
to do this identity
it's incredibly detailed okay so go
there
take responsibility for your own
learning and take the initiative
to go and download those documents
you'll also find
past hsc exams this is charles sturt
university
they have tons of great resources not
just for hsc but that's where most of
their time is spent
that's my old website it's from my old
school as you can see i'm trying to put
it onto my new one but
i'm busy so but you can go and have a
look there there's plenty of resources
worksheets
explanations um videos you can go and
have a look and i hope it's helpful too
okay